all right
movie retrospective yeah doing this on a
classic man rambo rambo first blood
first i'm pretty sure i got this deluxe
uh
blu-ray from uh friend of ours uh of the
show named louie uh uh hernandez yeah
yeah
i think i think hernandez sent that to
me i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure it's
a real nice uh blu-ray got a lot of x
uh extras and stuff on it i haven't
really watched all the extras on it yet
but we just watched that last night and
man it was good to see that movie again
i know i hadn't seen it in years and
years and that's the thing it's kind of
like
so this movie um this was i i want to
say too that in the patreon poll that
was like actually a three-way tie for
what movies to do this week
but because first blood was one of the
ones that was in the three-way tie i
just asked tom to
yeah because i was like i'm not
reviewing three movies this week for
gracing
what's cool about that movie is that
it's an
action movie but it was one of the early
action movies that i considered to be
an early action movie of the 80s the
genre had not really become
a meme yet it had elements of an action
movie but
it wasn't so crystallized to where it
was a formula
it also had elements of of
horror movie and social commentary and
just a really good movie man it was um
a lot like rocky in a certain way kind
of a story of an underdog
who comes out in a way kind of like a
downtrodden champion
yeah and a little bit of an anti-hero
too i guess yeah
but yeah so this came out in 1982 and
like you were saying about sort of the
action movies of the 80s i think a lot
of people
when they when they talk about action
movies from the 80s they kind of talk
about real over-the-top [ __ ] you know i
mean like everything's blowing up but
everything's no
nobody's running out of ammo which i the
first real
action movie was commando which was also
[ __ ] excellent
and then commando was arnold's version
of first blood
and that i think that kind of started
the
the [ __ ] bromance between the two
where these guys were in this [ __ ]
weird competition with each other they
eventually became friends but
they were all trying to top each other
there are scenes in this movie then i'd
say oh that's where
that's where [ __ ] arnie did the [ __ ]
you know that's that's why arnold
arnie did uh jumped off that cliff and
predator won
because he was hanging from that cliff
and [ __ ] rabbit there's all kinds of
good [ __ ]
in there but yeah so i i think that
people's perception of these kind of
over-the-top action movies from the 80s
that doesn't stem so much from this one
i think that stems maybe from the
sequel which was a lot more overblown
and a lot more kind of
over the top you know what i mean if i
remember correctly though the sequel to
this was like a response from
to commando though i think yeah they i
think they started getting like more and
more ridiculous and
more cartoonish like over time yeah
commando was when all of a sudden an
action movie became the action movie i
was thinking of it's like a [ __ ]
video game
yeah yeah yeah you don't talk about yeah
yeah this one is not like that at all
really and
a lot of people have said that this is
probably more an
action thriller i guess you could call
it it's not a straight ahead you know
yes there's explosions yes there's gun
fights yes there's violence
but it there's a lot more going on in it
than that there's like a lot
bigger story social commentary a lot of
social commentary a lot of
um actual kind of like an emotional kind
of thing
and the thing about it too the the thing
about the ending
is that i like that this one doesn't
have the ending isn't just this big
because i i feel like a lot of action
movies in the 80s had like you know your
your good guy and your bad guy having
like a big uh
you know kind of final boss fight you
know like at the end and this one didn't
really have that no he walks away from
it which i thought was kind of a cool
uh way of doing it now there's two
different endings to this movie and
this version has both endings the
theatrical ending
rambo gives up the deleted
ending is a lot better i didn't know
about it until modern times i've already
seen it i haven't seen
i haven't seen it on this blu-ray yet
though and the
the original ending really was going to
be
that um rambo dies yeah
and uh that actually is a much
better ending in terms of dramatic
impact it makes a lot more
sense it does yeah but
you have to understand the context of
the time in which this movie came out
this was a statement in support of
vietnam veterans that were still kind of
catching a lot of flack in society in 82
they were
my dad was in vietnam he was uh in the
navy okay
and that's another [ __ ] story right
there
during this time there were a lot of
young vietnam veterans still and
um the original ending would have been
really [ __ ] dark and a lot of [ __ ]
heavy [ __ ] to lay on those dudes i
i think i think stallone and his team
did the right thing by
giving it a little bit more of a
positive ending that there was hope for
the future
yeah i mean they shot both endings and i
want to get too into the book because
this is based on a book in case you
didn't know uh which i actually did read
about 10 years ago
um but i think the main thing i think a
lot of people thought it's like oh they
just wanted to make sequels
i don't know if they were thinking that
at the time i think that
it was just the fact that they showed
both endings to
um to test audiences and test audiences
didn't like
that he died at the end yeah because
they thought we got so invested in his
character and it's like
it seemed like a waste of the you know
they wanted to see him live so that's um
why they ended up he didn't get away
obviously because he got arrested but
for all of the havoc that he caused
but um you know they they just didn't
want to see him die after all that yeah
even though i do agree that it is a more
impactful ending yeah and artistically
that made a lot more
sense yeah um you created me you have to
kill me
that's the [ __ ] but man there were a
lot of [ __ ] young vietnam veterans
running around
and that's not the ending that they
wanted to see they didn't feel like they
were defeated by that
yeah the you know by vietnam you know
what i mean they they
it was a different era there was no
social media back then
the united states knew what war was
from the aspect of say like
world war ii maybe korea
vietnam was a very new kind of war it
was nowadays what you would call
a corporate forever war but
the guys that were fighting it were
being drafted and they didn't know what
that was
now we know exactly what that was uh
well because there was no internet
mainstream american society didn't
didn't know
what vietnam really was my dad was
in that war and i've talked to him a
couple years ago about
it and he didn't know what vietnam was
and he was in it
yeah talking to him more recently now
that
he's had more exposure things like
[ __ ]
stuff that information that's coming out
of the internet and politics today
my dad now finally gets it
what a forever war was and what general
eisenhower was warning about
the the misplaced powers you know of the
military
industrial complex it took a long time
for that to become
in the american public sphere
and america is addicted to that and
that's what this movie is about
it was one of the first movies that
talked about
the ramifications of these forever wars
because vietnam was not a war no war was
ever declared it was just a police
action
yeah very limited police action we got
involved in a civil war between north
and
south vietnam american the american
people had nothing to gain from it it
didn't even really have much to do with
communism
and more was a way of just
keeping generals promoted and keeping
military corporations flush with money
and developing military tactics and
developing big corporate contracts with
bell
and [ __ ] cult and to keep
the economy going you know america's
economy a lot of it has to do with war
production
and that's what that [ __ ] was about and
when i was in service
i thought it was gone no turned out
i joined up for the first gulf war you
know
and that seemed like that might have
been a legitimate war but then a couple
years later they said oh by by the way
we're the us army is no longer a war
fighting
outfit we're gonna prepare to conduct
operations
other than war and then the next thing
you know they're sending guys to them
operation just cause down in somalia
and it becomes that again and then it
just becomes that over and over and over
again and it
no well so in that sense i think it's
good
that the movie version of rambo made him
more sympathetic
you know yes he does um some bad
things obviously like he pretty much
[ __ ] up this whole entire town
so um what was his anger and his
frustration right
but he's still a sympathetic character
they draft back in those days they had
back in vietnam they had drafts they
don't have drafts anymore because you
get dudes like that it's uncontrollable
now what they do most of the [ __ ]
good [ __ ]
is run by [ __ ] terrorists that we
hire
terrorists from other [ __ ] countries
mercenaries from other countries
and uh corporations and corporate
warfare
legal warfare and then our troops just
kind of sit around and act like law
enforcement
operations other than war that's [ __ ]
crazy because they don't want to make
dudes like that anymore
where you draft a dude off the street
train him up
and then go have him fight a war that
they're that they never intended to win
it's just to keep contracts running and
of course there's gonna be a lot of
anger and bitter
bitterness because all his friends have
been killed doing stupid [ __ ]
you know what i mean and then he comes
back home and nobody really knows
what the war was about because they
didn't really didn't have anything to do
with them
and everybody's yes they're like you're
some kind of baby killer what the hell
wrong you know they don't really you
know the american public didn't even
know what had happened
and i yeah because i feel like around
that time period all the a lot of the
soldiers coming back from vietnam
because particularly because we had lost
it
um you know or it didn't go the way this
morning
just left it yeah and so i feel like
people had a lot of resentment towards
the soldiers because they didn't really
know what was going on over there either
so
they got treated really badly when they
came back so the thing about it so
in case you didn't know like i said this
is based on um
a novel which is also called first blood
it came out in 1972
by david morrell now the novel
i guess like i said i read it about 10
years ago and it was it's pretty good
it's not very long i
remember it being kind of short the
story of it is similar
but i will say that in the book rambo
is a much less sympathetic character he
kills everybody yeah he kills everybody
and he doesn't like i think he kills
[ __ ] i don't even remember how many
people he killed like i think in the
first um when they were first talking
about because they were talking about
making this into a movie like ever since
the book came out because the book was
like a bestseller or was at least really
popular
so all the first iterations of the
script
were hewed much closer to the novel you
know because i think the first three
versions of it had him killing 16 people
and him dying it then killing himself
now at the end of the book
he um him and uh tesol the
sheriff they kind of get into a gun
battle and they wound each other
tesla's dying and then troutman the
colonel
um kills rambo
and uh he's already wounded and he kills
him
like with a shotgun in the back of the
head or something like that and then he
sits with the sheriff
like and while the sheriff's dying so
that's how the book ends
but as i said they they kind of made it
where he killed himself in the
in the other ending for this but
you know i people thought that was just
too bleak or whatever
but he but rambo doesn't really
kill anybody in this on purpose now he
wounds a lot of people and he blows a
lot of [ __ ] up and he does a lot of
property damage
but the one dude that dies that won one
of the
several [ __ ] cops in this um
that was kind of that dude's own fault
because he was like hanging out of the
[ __ ] helicopter like trying to shoot
at rambo
and no he didn't kill anybody
that dude fell out of that helicopter
that was his own fault and then later
that um the bad guy cop was shooting at
rambo rambo kind of defended himself
shot him through the legs but didn't
kill him yeah he lived he lived
yeah so yeah so i didn't kill anybody
and that did open it up for another
sequel
yeah because yeah he did blow up a
couple of buildings
and people were looking for him but he
was mostly just running
yeah um he did um shoot some dogs
remember this they they attacked he
stabbed the dog stabbed the dogs that's
right
because he had that hunting knife i
thought he shot the dude he shot the
dude that had the hunting dog
the the the uh the dog he shot him in
the leg all right i'm in the legs yeah
so like i said he did wound a bunch of
people yeah but
the one cop that fell out he just fell
out of the helicopter i mean you could
you could argue that he was trying to
murder him yeah that's what i mean so
that was kind of self-defense too
because all of them
all he did was throw a rock at the
helicopter like hey quit shooting at me
and he was hanging from the side of the
cliff and the guy in his head trying to
shoot him
yeah and he was trying to run which that
was very unusual in the 80s now you see
guys run from the cuff and they'll shoot
him in the back you know it's just as
[ __ ] up as society is right now
well okay so let's talk a little bit
about so like i said they've been trying
to
um adapt this novel all throughout the
1970s
and many of the first versions of the
script
were much closer to the book so they
were much darker um
you know rambo was much more clearly a
bad guy
so which is maybe why it didn't really
get off the ground
um initially interestingly they wanted
steve mcqueen
to play rambo he'd have been a little
too old that's what they determined they
said yeah he's a little too old to be a
vietnam veteran right around the time i
think this was 75 or 76 they were first
you know trying to make this into a
korean war yeah vietnam
yeah that's again that's why they ended
up going with someone younger now
obviously because stallone had done
rocky and it was like such a huge huge
success they finally got him involved
and then they got stallone in on the
writing process as well
so he also helps to uh co-write the
screenplay
yeah and um all right so
in case you haven't seen first blood i
don't know why you wouldn't have
but here's what happens in the movie so
poor john rambo
has come back from vietnam now he had
how long has he been back
for some reason i want to say about ten
years huh because i thought seven years
somebody said seven years
he must have left around the late 70s
yeah all right left theater in the late
70s
and this is taking place i think in 81
or 82 right
yeah it was shot in 81 and i don't see
any reason why it wasn't less than 10
around that time
i think somebody told me it was seven
years i don't remember he was just
walking around living off the land
i said he stank and he had his army
field jacket with america flag on it
yeah they didn't give a lot of backstory
like where he had come from he was only
in this particular area because he was
looking for the last
member of his team he said he couldn't
hold a job he didn't like him he didn't
like
work in the civilian world so he just he
walked around and lived off the land and
was looking for his buddies
yeah and they were all uh dead
yeah except for he went to the last
one's house because he had given him his
address or whatever
so at the very beginning like the first
scene of the movie he goes back
and um you know speaks to the dude's
wife or mom or whoever that is
and um she says yeah he died too he died
of cancer
from agent orange yeah so that was like
the last
one so at this point obviously uh
rambo's pretty bummed out about the [ __ ]
and so he ends up going to this town
called hope
um in the universe of the movie it's
supposed to be washington state although
they actually shot it in british
columbia
and they shot it in the wintertime so
you can see like how cold it is like
when he's walking down the street and
like [ __ ]
um you know and he had to run around in
the woods like with the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] wife-beater t-shirt on and
all that kind of stuff they said he was
like freezing his ass off
yeah but um so he ends up going to this
town
and the cop there played by brian
dennehy
but this was kind of like brian dennehy
had been in some stuff prior to this
he was not the first choice for this
role um there was like a bunch of other
actors that they had wanted to be in
this but they dropped out for whatever
reason
um but this ended up being like one of
his
biggest roles and this was kind of like
the thing that yes
this movie was a huge hit and it was and
they weren't really planning for this to
be a hit
i don't think they thought it was gonna
be that good i don't think hollywood it
wasn't
this wasn't the kind of movie that
hollywood wanted to make in those days
it just turned out that it had it got
backing and this
when it came out i mean i didn't see it
when it came out but i heard about it i
didn't see it until later
on vhs but um
everybody was talking about this movie
when it came out everybody
you know what's interesting too
according to sylvester stallone
the first initial cut of this movie i
can't even imagine this
the first initial cut of this movie was
like three and a half hours long
yeah and he him and his agent watched it
and they were like this is the worst
[ __ ] ever like this is going to ruin my
career
and so finally they edited it down to
like 93 minutes
and that was like the theatrical cut
that you see just like i can't imagine
what else was in there
just probably a lot of scenes you know
how they are they shoot scenes a lot of
scenes
yeah scenes three and a half hours long
scenes are looking at [ __ ]
yeah they do i guess so yeah but uh yeah
so three and a half hours i can't i'm
talking
yeah a bunch of talking they're talking
to each other cops talking to each other
yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] there
there's a lot of iconic
characters in this too you know what i
mean
like the cop what's what's the main cop
then the state police guy
yeah just the way the dynamic between
those two and then uh
rambo's carnal yeah actually shows that
what was it
what was his name troutman yeah troutman
shows up mike i think i think kirk
douglas was initially supposed to have
that role
but he dropped out i think because he
thought rambo should die at the end
yeah and uh he didn't like you know
because i'm telling you this wasn't
this wouldn't have flown in hollywood in
the 80s it was very anti-vietnam
war yet they wouldn't they wouldn't have
liked this um
but the child made character i mean he
is [ __ ]
he isn't an archetype in this in
in the in the [ __ ] action movie genre
and especially in this property i think
he was in three of these movies richard
crenna yeah he wasn't and he got brought
in at the last minute because like i
said kurt douglas was supposed to play
that role but he dropped out now the
problem with him is
i think he's great he i think he [ __ ]
does a great performance
it's not authentic that is not an
authentic military man of the of that
era first of all
the way he's wearing that beret i'd
[ __ ] pull that [ __ ] boy
you wear a [ __ ] beret all right he's
wearing that [ __ ] like a french painter
and [ __ ] that's
that he's got that [ __ ] totally wrong i
could tell they didn't [ __ ] shrink
that [ __ ] beret you got to put
bray as wool and when we wore them
things you had to put it in the water i
think
i now i think all infantry wears [ __ ]
black berets but in our days it was just
rangers
but i got issued an orange one for a
[ __ ] mfo mission
but they were wool and you had to put
them in the water get them wet
and then you had to let them shrink up
uh i forgot exactly how which i think we
put them in the dryer to shrink them up
as much as possible
and you had to put it on your head when
it was wet and let it [ __ ] form fit
there's a special way we had that [ __ ]
it had to be tight and then over your
eye it had the [ __ ] little board and
it had to come down
he had that [ __ ] poofed out like he was
[ __ ] jacques and [ __ ] you know
jacques pierre and [ __ ] you know that's
not how you wear a [ __ ] military
beret i can't want to [ __ ] throw that
thing and throwing it on the ground
and his and he's in his second overcoat
but it's not really well pressed
okay it's just he shows up in full
[ __ ] dress greens and [ __ ]
but it looks a little bit like a rag bag
and most of what he's saying
his dialogue is [ __ ] spot on for an
action movie
you know what i mean like well yeah yeah
but that's not
but a [ __ ] real colonel would never
talk that way that's like right out of
some kind of army recruitment film
it's just generic generic stereotypical
yeah but like i said movies in real life
yeah yeah it's very but i think it would
have been cooler
i don't i don't remember him being as
as as much of a [ __ ] propaganda
you know sounding [ __ ] mechanism in
the other movies that he sounded a
little more realistic but uh i can't
remember i haven't seen rainbows here
with you in a really long time
officers of that especially field grade
officers that time of that era
were uh crazy they were [ __ ] wild
asses
they were um you know [ __ ] i
i grew up around them in my military
academy you know but the the older
generations of [ __ ] field grade
officers were uh wild asses
and they were funny a better example the
way they actually
acted would be like in star trek
enterprise
[ __ ] general shrand or commander
shrand it was played by [ __ ] uh
same dude that uh jeffrey combs
yeah jeffrey combs did it perfectly
that's exactly the way
the old generation officers were from
the korean war vietnam war era
but um yeah that was that was only
problem with the movie is that he
sounded a little fake the rest of the
characters sounded kind of realistic
yeah i mean so so poor rambo gets to
this [ __ ] town right
this dinky ass little you know butthole
town
and he's basically just wandering
through there looking for a [ __ ]
diner or some [ __ ]
and brian dennehy playing sheriff teasel
decides i don't like the look of this
it's you [ __ ] hippie or whatever like
his hair is too long and he looks like a
drifter
[ __ ] drifter you let one in here all
there they'll tell all their drifter
friends and all that other kind of [ __ ]
so he basically takes a dislike to him
like immediately
he's like get in the car and he just
takes him to the edge of town and i was
like yeah get out of here
now at this point and because we were
watching this last night and we said now
probably you can you can blame rambo
for just not going man [ __ ] that place
and just keep walking
he did turn around and go back to that
town and that's what started all the
trouble
yeah well his his his his car i can
understand why he's not as colonel said
hey man this is partly you you the one
that made this you know
it was it was it's a good movie you know
if you haven't seen it then
you're kind of missing out on it it's
it's pretty good movie well i mean it's
easily
one of the best if not if not the best
action movies in the 80s and i mean and
i mean like i said it's
the thing that's cool about it it
doesn't have it has some over-the-top
[ __ ] in it but not
to the extent that some of the ones in
the you know later the mid to late 80s
had
where everything was just like
ridiculously overblown and just like
everything was a big explosion
this has that too this has like a lot of
really good action sequences
and you know stallone did most of his
own stunts he did all this other kind of
stuff
so yeah so like i said he decides to
come back in town the cops
are dicks um except for david caruso
he's like the only one that's like a
good he would david caruso was such a
baby in this i can't
he was so young yeah i like that touch
that uh
that the younger cops were kind of like
hey let's not really [ __ ] was like
let's can we not it's like holy crap it
was the older cops that had [ __ ] egos
and [ __ ] and you know it was funny they
were all these older overweight cops
mad at the [ __ ] hot young vietnam guy
well
yeah they even [ __ ] stripped him down
and [ __ ] hit him with a water hose
and [ __ ]
and trying to try to cut his hair see i
was kind of like what i'm like this is
kind of what the hell's going on here
man
yeah that's kind of what i always think
about yeah i mean this
it is a small town and i guess they
didn't have anything better to do than
just
randomly terrorize the person that was
just walking through town not doing
anything
so so it's like even though you can say
that rambo's reaction to
what happened to him was a little over
the top
um but you can't [ __ ] blame the guy i
mean you know
it's like he was just walking he was
just trying to get a [ __ ] burger or
something
the cops start [ __ ] with him and they
start and then he starts having [ __ ]
nom flashbacks from when he was a pow
and then he just you know he's freaking
out and he just starts like kicking them
and
punching their lights out and [ __ ] like
that which like i said deservedly so
because a lot of those cops were douches
and then they just wouldn't stop [ __ ]
with them like they just kept and like i
said i was watching another review of
this and he said
pretty much the same exact thing that
you said he's like that this
this whole situation could have been
avoided if
that cop didn't have such a gigantic ego
that he's just like oh this dude
that was just wandering through here and
looks like a scumbag
um you know he dared to defy me me and
my tiny little [ __ ] town
my little kingdom where he's you know
what i think even rambo calls him king
[ __ ] cop like
that's exactly what he is so he's like
you came in my little
dinky ass domain and made me look bad
and wouldn't do what i said
so now he's just gonna go to the [ __ ]
ends of the earth even when he gets
his people killed or injured it's like
he doesn't care he's just going to keep
on going yeah rambo tells him
gets his hands on him after he [ __ ]
hurt a lot of his dudes gets his hands
on him puts a [ __ ] knife in his
throat and he goes maybe back in the
world you know
you have power but out here this is my
world you know
which is all true yeah because he was he
was
you know it's all about [ __ ] ambush
counter ambush and
living off the land and but it was
called kind of a [ __ ] hopeless it was
a hopeless thing you couldn't really
they knew his name so there was no way
that they knew they knew he was
john rambo so there was no escape they
were actually getting
green beret congressional medal and all
that kind of stuff they knew exactly who
it was so now that like you kind of have
a dumb
kind and to me i'm watching and i'm
waiting it was like my ramble's kind of
dumb i just would have gone to the next
town
i would have too but if that had
happened that would have been really
funny if he had just like kept walking
and then they just rolled the credits
you wouldn't have had a baby and some of
it was kind of some of it was a little
hokey you know kind of contrived because
the chances are
what was more there wasn't a big a lot
of animosity between
[ __ ] veterans and cops during that
era all right what really would have
happened
most likely had the cops seen him and
wanted to get rid of him
they went oh man you know who are you oh
you're you're a veteran oh [ __ ] yeah
once you come to the station get
yourself cleaned up get something to eat
and it would have fed him probably there
with the cops
and then moved him along in the town it
was a little town that would be i mean
well that would have been the wisest
move on everyone's party i would have
probably really going to happen hey you
want to ride around
and uh go get some donuts you know or
some [ __ ] like that and that'd be the
best way to keep an eye on him
and get rid of him clean him up feed him
and pass him along after he had the
sheriff been smart he would have done
that
and then and then the whole town
wouldn't have got blown up real good
well that well like i said i think
that's kind of one of the points of the
story was that the sheriff's ego
got in the way of him just like making
the most rational decision yeah
you know he just came out he just had to
be a dick he just had to make everything
more difficult
and that you know led to all of this
[ __ ] happening if the sheriff was
reasonable there wouldn't have been a
movie
well yeah that's that's what it but you
know in real life most
law enforcement agents know the [ __ ]
know how to get what they want out of
people without resorting to [ __ ]
drastic [ __ ] they just would have
manipulated him
yeah come on with the station man
[ __ ] you know get yourself cleaned up
get something to eat you know on that
where are you going next
you know and then they just moved them
out that's probably what they what they
would have done in a little town
yeah i mean [ __ ] they might have even
hey you want us to we'll buy you a train
ticket or yeah
you know or a bus ticket or something
like that you want a job around station
yeah that seems like the easiest thing
see that would have been like so much
better for all involved yeah
but yeah so like i said this came out in
uh 82 and it's weird because
the reviews of it initially when it
first came out now it made a [ __ ] ton of
money i think it only cost
15 million to make it and it ended up
making 125 million
um the reviews at the time were
mixed i think ebert liked it um some
other ones were like meh
a lot of people didn't like the ending i
i think even roger ebert didn't like the
end him because
he thought you know he thought rambo
should have died because that's made
more sense the story
made more sense with the story but it's
really weird how
it's kind of one of those cases where
you know it's easier to see things like
when you have some years to look back
upon it
like you know kind of the framework of
the context of the movie like you know
when
when you look back with hindsight
because i think like the reviews were
kind of mixed and everyone was like
at the time but then like a few years go
by
and people started to appreciate it a
lot more you know what i mean
so it was kind of another one of those
things but it was like really successful
at the time
fun fact this was released in china in
1985
and was the first hollywood blockbuster
to be released in china
and made and sold the most tickets in
china
for a hollywood movie up until 2018.
okay so that's how like popular this is
as good as rocky
easy oh yeah i liked it yeah it's like
it's a different thing but
you could really see too how what talent
uh stallone had as a writer which i
think we've talked about before
and i think people because he it's kind
of a shame because i feel like the
sequels
went more into the kind of meathead hey
we're just going to blow everything up
kind of thing
like just this over the top um and i
think so i think that stallone got um
maybe a little bit typecast with that
and i think people forgot like
what a good actor he was because if you
see
in this movie like for most of the movie
he doesn't really have a lot of lines
like a lot of his um
a lot of his emotions and stuff are just
conveyed through his face as like facial
expressions in his body language
a lot of physical activity and it's a
lot of physical acting as well
and so and it's really really good and
then at the end
like when he has that [ __ ] emotional
breakdown like in the room with troutman
where he's talking about you know being
in a bar in saigon and like his friend
blowing up like right next to him and
him trying to hold all the pieces of the
dude together and
he's just like completely a completely
broken man and like everything that's
been
that he's been holding within him you
know through the whole movie just comes
like pouring out
a big torrent yeah and it's just it's
really really good
and i think that's another thing that
makes this
one of the best action movies is because
it doesn't have the ending that you
expect where it's just kind of like
you know oh the big showdown between you
know good and bad or whatever
it has this big like a kind of emotional
thing at the end where he just
you know where he just like lets
everything out and he's just like
[ __ ] crying and freaking out
yeah those other kind of the formula had
not been perfected yet
yeah or like you know it hadn't been
codified eventually
this [ __ ] starts going on in into stuff
like red scorpion
which was the russian version of rambo
all right dolph lundgren
which i remember enjoying it in the day
but it probably sucked i'd have to go
back and see it again
those action movies are fun yeah they're
just scorpions
but they're but you know they're real
over the top and it's like you know but
i think that's why a lot of people like
them
it had cool guns in it a lot of the ones
that i was issued
made the m60 famous i was an m60 gunner
in in korea
at the 506th [ __ ] camp greaves
in the early 90s and uh
that did that picture of [ __ ] rambo
there [ __ ]
holding a m60 hip firing it and firing
it from the shoulder and stuff you know
what i mean that just became like an
iconic
can you fire an m60 from the shoulder
hell yes you can
yeah it's not that heavy about 20 pounds
maybe but
yeah you can do it um also it uh had um
cult sp ones that's what the cops are
carrying uh and then the national guard
showed up with uh m16a1s
i was issued a1 only in basic training
after that we got the a2 let me tell you
young guys that came up
shooting these m4 carbines and stuff
there's nothing sweeter than those 20
inch [ __ ]
20 inch barreled a1s with the light
barrel and
the a2 was nice too a little heavier
barrel but that [ __ ] light
the real light m16a1 with the long gas
system and everything just a sweet
shooting sweet shooting rifle like
shooting 22 long rifle
um real fast follow-up shots light
real light um a lot lighter than a uh
say like a a4
or an a3 nowadays
the only reason the only reason why they
got rid of those little pencil barrels
is because as they got hot
as you continued firing them not only
did the shot group open up it also
shifted from the sights a little bit now
it would go back
to where it was once the barrel cooled
off but with extensive firing it became
kind of
um inaccurate uh recently they fixed
that though
there's a way to relieve the pressure
inside that barrel
during some process there's a company
called faxin that makes
pencil barrels of all different lengths
10 and a half inch
all the way up to i think you can even
get a 20 inch 18 16
inches barrels and they're they weigh
next to nothing
and they're very accurate and it does
open up a little bit as it gets hot
the shot group but it doesn't shift from
the sides so you can run a red dot
optics and everything
very accurate and if you go back to
eugene stoner's original
concept of a lightweight ar
rifle you know like a five pound four
and a half pound
five pound rifle [ __ ] it's a big
difference it's nice
real nice especially with the long gas
system in there
see what else is in there and i've shot
them all even [ __ ]
10.5 inch commando carbines and all that
i've shot all that [ __ ]
i'd still like that i like the a1 the a1
was [ __ ] awesome
um and the a2 the a2 is good too
but uh good a lot of interesting guns of
the 80s were in there
yeah so if you're into it can i just say
another fun fact that i just found out
today
was that apparently they're going to be
doing
bollywood remakes of rambo
the expendables and three other kind of
iconic american action movies
i can't do a bollywood remake with all
indian cast
yeah i gotta see it but is it gonna be
rambo
or is it gonna be a character like rambo
um i don't know i couldn't really
determine like i kind of read a little
bit about it i think
i don't know i mean i think it's gonna
be like rambo but
maybe with different names and stuff i'm
not really sure
but yeah i think they're doing the
expendables and stuff too i mean because
obviously he's going to be in the indian
army instead of right yeah he has to be
in the indian army right
i know that they're doing some stuff
against china so maybe i think they're
fighting china right now or there's some
kind of border war with china so that's
maybe whether
is that where they're going to be set
you could do expendables because
they were doing maritime [ __ ]
anti-piracy missions and
expendables and doing espionage so you
know you could
yeah i mean cannibals could be from any
country yeah i mean that
that formula could just be you know they
they could
they could do that anywhere i'd watch
that i probably would too
i did not have a job in [ __ ] modern
day hollywood not gonna lie i'd probably
watch that yeah yeah
but yeah that's the thing is so if
you've only seen
the later rambo movies now i feel like
the fourth rambo that was the super gory
one right
yeah that's what actually my favorite
ones
was first blood and then number four
which is the fight continues
yeah that's my two favorite ones well
because those two and i think
most per 99 percent of people would
probably agree with you
two was pretty good three was like an
over top action movie you could tell
that
the two was pretty over the top too i
got it yeah but and then um the last one
uh the one where he's fighting the
mexican cartels
it was okay but man it left me wanting
some stuff it's like there wasn't enough
action in it
and it turned out that there was some
stuff cut out
i'd like to see the uncut version yeah
remember how he cut that one dude's head
off but they didn't show it yeah
i think they show it in the uncensored
version i want to see it that's what i
heard
that they did show them cutting the head
off i mean i heard that i don't know if
it was yeah or not
i'd like to see it it's probably better
it's like
the theatrical release of expendables
three
isn't any good but if you have the uh
the blu-ray the the director's cut it's
much better
yeah yeah because three had they had to
cut out all the cousin because
[ __ ] what's his name was in it
who chuck norris chuck norris will [ __ ]
a movie up
well yeah you can't you can't say you
can't say damn around [ __ ] chuck
norris you won't be in that movie
and they just what a baby i'd be like
you know nobody likes you that much
anyway
there's a lot of stuff that was cut out
and it didn't make any sense evidently
in the theatrical cup the um
the blu-ray extended cut that i have is
[ __ ] great uh that's my favorite one
was part three
yeah yeah because it's it's crazy i mean
it's [ __ ] zany but it's good well
yeah
but yes antonio banderas is [ __ ]
great in it
i always kind of liked him he's kind of
a cool dude um
but yeah so if if your whole conception
of rambo
is like from the second and third movie
this kind of like over-the-top
kind of thing um then probably you
should watch first blood because
it's a much more serious yeah still an
action movie but it has like more of a
thriller more of a psychological
type of thing it kind of feels
spielbergian did you notice that
i kind of thought like the parts where
he was in the woods where the cops were
having and he was like kind of set in
traps
almost um it almost kind of seemed jerry
goldsmith did the score for this and
it's actually the score is really good
it it almost had a friday the 13th kind
of thing there for a second
like so in some of the uh woods shots
like when it was getting dark or the
storm was coming or whatever i said this
almost looks like a
slasher movie a little bit but um
and two like where they shot it like i
said in british columbia
holy crap that was like gorgeous i
thought like where the cliff
was and everything like where he was
climbing down the cliff and the dude was
shooting at him and stuff
that's like some um that's some big like
national park up there or something like
that and like all the
mountains had like [ __ ] fog because
like i said it was winter time
but yeah it was like you know nice
cinematography just good just good score
good acting it's just like a
it's just a [ __ ] classic man and uh
yeah so
i think and like i said i'm pretty sure
it was louis that dennis sent us this it
was just
a couple of days ago let's look it i
don't know up down i don't know
but yeah so uh that's the steel book
blu-ray there
so thanks very much for that and i guess
that'll do it for you have anything else
you want to say about first blood all
right so that'll do it for
this movie retrospective and we'll see
on the next one
bye